well thank you for joining us today and
welcome to the first session of
agrogenomics crack on day two of the apj
genetic solution
tour 2020. my name is ryan harvey and i
am your moderator for this vision
in this session we will hear about the
iron torrent aggressive
targeted genotyping by sequencing
platform
and it's used for agrogenomics
applications
uh just a note if you have any questions
that arise during the following
presentations we encourage you to submit
them in the questions and answers box
and our speakers will address your
questions following the presentations
firstly today we will hear from dr
tapashima who is a researcher at the
naro institute for crop science in japan
today he will be talking to us about how
the iron torrent ampliseq
platform our predecessor to the aggra
seek platform
was used in his laboratory for the
identification of genetic loci
associated with self-compatibility
pre-harvest sprouting
and maturity time welcome dr takashima
[Music]
center
foreign
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
they
um
[Music]
foreign
foreign
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
great thank you very much for the
excellent talk dr takashima
we will now be moving into the live q
and a section here and
uh just uh let's have a look here so
there's a couple questions coming
through now
and the first one dr pacquiao is are
there any plants that show
heteromorphic cell incompatibility
properties
well thank you for questions so
preliminar
channel um linux are showing the
heteronormal effects self in quality
properly
thank you
thank you we have another question here
as well
is this the most common strategy to drop
scaffold
onto linkage maps but not onto physical
maps
so i think it's commonly
used technically to create the shield
workers
[Music]
so well
uh when converting a draft candle into a
shadow molecule
i think there is a method to drop each
scaffold
on the linkage map and look at the
linkage relationship to create
a chromosome-based genome database
so however in this case it seems
that there is no level on the method of
dropping scaffolds on the linkage map by
performing ktl sec
on the terrestrial cells have been
finally
defeated like this time thank you
thank you we have another christian here
as well
on the slide titled as distribution of
phf tolerance cross a you explain that
the locus
of pre-harvest sprouting is probably
dominated by two major genes from the
pattern of distribution
how did you find that out
yeah it is expected at the graph
that it can be applied to two dominant
gene segregation pattern so i mean the
rate of the 15
to one so for example
if more polygen are involved it will
take
a gauss distribution with a peak around
the center of the parents
so on the other hand if margin locus is
dominant so you know
the ratio is three to one the number of
individuals
will be higher in the pattern that is
easy to shop for harvest sprouting
thank you
thank you we have another question here
as well do you think that this
methodology is efficient for
the species which does have a draft
genome that does not have a physical map
yes i think so
thank you and a couple more questions
here as well uh the 300 markers
for linkage map used not for genome
wide linkage map but for connecting the
100 selected marker segments
so 300 markers are used to
create a linkage map of the whole gun
and to analyze in which diesel 100
selected markers are gathered on the
linkage map
so if we do not do these methods
we will not know if the 100 selected
smart
clustered at one logos was
scattered in the multiple divisions
thank you
thanks and another question here as well
are there any other conditions needed
for applying this method
i think there will be no problem if
we can properly select a ganon white
marker
that can construct ringcase map
thank you
great thank you very much for that dr
takashima we'll just wait and see if
there's any other questions that come
through in the next minute or two
otherwise thank you very very much for
that wonderful presentation
yeah thank you
right so next we will hear from dr
srinivas chaturang
who is our global product manager in our
aggregate genomics business
srinivas is based out of austin texas
and is responsible for the portfolio of
products
supporting agrogenomics including agric
genotyping by sequencing
ce sequencing as well as working with
the qpcr my
and microarray teams supporting
agrogenomics solutions
today srinivas will be talking about how
the agriseq targeted gbs
is successfully being used as a high
throughput customizable and
cost-effective genotype in solution and
aquaculture
animal plant breeding studies as well as
parentage testing and genetic purity
welcome trinity
hello everybody thanks for joining us on
the genetic solutions tour
today i inspired by the
research efforts of several scientists
like dr sakishima who have used the iron
amplifique
technology to discover genetic loci
in plants and animals the thermo fisher
scientific
agribusiness r d team developed the
agric targeted gbs technology
using the same iron torrent next
generation sequencing platform
and the highly efficient mpc chemistry
for targeted agriculture applications
today i'm going to talk about the
aggregate targeted gbs platform
and how it has become a fast and
affordable
genotyping by sequencing solution
for breeding programs in plants animals
and aquaculture
next generation sequencing is actually a
very
innovative and informative technology
however it is very complex and it
requires
technical expertise and highly qualified
trained scientists to be able to handle
the complex workflows
especially in identifying the specific
markers
of their interest and how do you design
a targeted panel which is very highly
specific
and sensitive given the all the genomic
complications
across various species i mean plants
have a very complex genome
similarly each and every animal species
has their own genomic complexities
and one really needs to have the
expertise to understand
and navigate through all of that and on
top of that
the sequencing technology gives out you
a deluge of data you really need help
in understanding the various pipelines
to make sense
of the data you need bioinformatician
support
to really help you see through all that
i mean sometimes you get megabytes of
data per sample and gigabytes of data
per run
and to really make sense of all of this
you
really need trained personnel and then
of course the industry has multiple data
formats
that you need to work through and
understand so these are several
challenges
that especially for an agriculture
industry it's becoming very
daunting to apply the next generation
sequencing platform
the thermal fissure scientific has
always been a technology enabler
providing the building blocks we have
been serving the agri industry for the
past
several decades and depending on
what the customer needs and where they
are
in their genomic journey whether are
they doing
early discovery phase after whole genome
sequencing
looking at genome-wide association
studies and
doing some genomic selections and
predictions where they are looking at
millions and hundreds and thousands of
markers we have the microarray platform
that helps them with those applications
similarly if they are developing new
markers
and new loci that they are really
researching and coming up
with uh using our pcr or
our sanger sequencing platforms uh
whether for seat using
or looking at microsatellite markers for
parentage verifications in
animals we have all these platforms
but now as the
customer is trying to add more relevant
markers
or make it more get you more genetic
value into their breeding program
or likewise are you're trying to
streamline
and optimize which markers are really
essential for you
and trying to develop a known target
list that is
essential for your marker assisted
selection or breeding program
uh we have uh utilized the targeted gps
platform develop that platform
to help with this mid density range
which provides you a lot of flexibility
and value
and in fact you can use our amplici
chemistry which is very efficient
for multiplexing uh several thousand
markers it could be as small as 50
markers all the way up to 5000 or even
up to 10
000 markers all of this reaction
is performed in one single droplet
reaction
and that's the power of the
technology that uh the agric targeted
gps brings forward
for our customers especially focusing on
market
market assisted selection and breathing
in plants animals aquaculture
and its thermo fisher scientific have
been providing these solutions across
the continuum in fact
we believe in providing a complete
solution we have several sample prep
solutions that are specific to plants
versus animals or
aquaculture we could always bring
in those uh and augment our agric
technology where it
the genotyping solution starts with
designing custom panels
followed by using the modified
reformatted amplitude chemistry to feed
to shoot the high agriculture throughput
and scalability
using barcodes and then uh the
sequencing the ion torrent sequencing
platform
and then we cap it with the data
analysis tools
that gives you a complete solution
for your needs in terms of the workflow
it is
a very simplified workflow so for the
angry customers to adapt
it starts with first designing your your
panel
and our bioinformatics team design team
provides a great service in working with
you in developing
highly high performing panels so using
those panels and after you have
isolated your dna using one of our
sample prep solutions you start the
library construction process
using that panel along with the uh
the agri-seq library kit and the
barcodes
so you amplify your targets and then
barcode them
and once the barcoded libraries are
normalized
then they are loaded onto the templating
platform
the whole library construction takes
about six to seven hours
and if you are doing a 96 well protocol
you can do it manually
it includes about three hours of actual
manual
work in the six to seven hours and it is
very automatic
uh automatable and you could actually
increase your throughput by
uh implementing a 384 well format
uh and the hands-on time then becomes
just one hour
once your libraries are barcoded and
normalized then you are adding that onto
the chip on an iron chef
where the templating happens overnight
it is fully automated
you can load all the reagents and the
chip and the libraries and go home and
the next day morning
you come in and take out the chip and
load on to the sequencer for sequencing
irrespective of how many samples and how
large your panel
is the sequencing on the ion tolerance
sequencer
only takes two and a half hours it's all
automated
your hands on time is only 15 minutes to
turn the system
on and to load the chip and then to turn
it off and do the washes so it's
very automated and then it takes about
six hours for the raw data to be
converted
and then for the complete analysis to
happen it takes anywhere between six
to 24 hours so your entire workflow from
sample to data and results
is about three days and it is very
highly scalable because you can totally
automate it
and you can reduce the hands-on time and
reduce the errors
and increase the efficiency
and the whole system is really very
nicely integrated on our iron gene
studio system you have the iron torrent
server which
actually is where all the data is stored
the torrent suite software helps you
plan your entire run
right from the beginning of of labeling
your samples and
assigning the barcodes and planning your
runs and all the primary data is stored
and analyzed here
where the electrical signals the raw
signals are converted to base calls
and the alignment and base alignments
are are made
once all of this is done then the
variant caller plug-in is used and the
coverage plugin is used
they make the call for the presence or
absence of the variant
and all that data is further analyzed
and summarized for you using the
aggressive
sum toolkit and it provides you
actionable genotypes
so this entire need of of trying to go
back and look at raw data is taken away
because
the agri-sum toolkit really summarizes
everything for you
and gives you the actionable genotypes
in a format
that you can use
so the interpretation what does the
agri-sum toolkit do
and how it makes the results really uh
easy
is that it it summarizes the entire run
for you
showing you what types of markers were
involved in the panel
where their snips deletions insertions
how many amplicons were there
and what's the mean coverage and the
call rate it gives you
the marker performance and it can be
categorized into
any into several bins as per your
requirement
and similarly for the sample call rates
and we use the simple traffic signal
like green being good
yellow or oranges be watchful and
red is that things have failed go check
out what has happened
the agmvsum toolkit also presents this
data
into very easy interpretable format
in in bar graph so on this bar graph on
the
y-axis you have the number of samples
and
on the x-axis you have the call rate
range
and then you look at a graph like this
where you are seeing
green bars which is good and wherever
you are seeing red bars that means it is
bad and these samples have failed or
need to be re-run
so you get an upfront idea how your
overall panel has performed how your
overall experiment has performed and you
can decide
on what the next steps are it also gives
you additional graphs where you can do a
quick comparison why has my
sample failed so it will show you the
mean depth or coverage
of the run and how the call rates are so
you can quickly make those associations
and decide what needs to be performed so
it kind of really helps you to do
a very easy uh overview
upfront and then it provides you the
capability of downloading the data
in a format that you are able to do
downstream analysis
we normally give the genotype matrix
which is the reference versus variant
calls
for all these the samples and then we
also give you
a top bottom format which most micro
customers are used to or the parent-page
format which is recommended
by associations like isage
the ing studio system is really scalable
and flexible the flexibility comes in
with the technology
it's the same sequencers whether it is
our base model
the s5 and the s plus or the s
prime which is the high powerful system
with an
integrated server along with it and
depend and it's the same system that can
be used for multiple applications
though here we are concentrating on
plant and animal breeding application
and the same sequencer is used and
depending on your throughput you can
always
change or you can always change your
your throughput using a different type
of chip
if you have a smaller number of samples
that you want to quickly test
you can use a smaller chip like say for
example which gives you between three to
five million reads
you can test about 125 plus markers for
or
or up to 400 samples or you can use a
large
550 chip which is giving you the
capacity to test up to 130 million data
points
where you can test anywhere between 800
to 5000 markers
for about 260 to 1536 samples
so the system is designed such a way
that it
easily provides you the capability to
scale and it's also very flexible
so overall the agri-sum
targeted gbs platform is very flexible
it
it allows you to screen for multiple
markers
snips multi-nucleotide polymorphisms
indels and various structural variants
you can do multi-species panels you can
run
at the same time multiple species you
can
gen it is a very powerful and scalable
platform
because you can totally automate it you
can run 1536 samples in one time
you can generate several novel genotypes
and you can also have the flexibility of
adding
or dropping markers and editing your
panels
so what all of this does is results in a
very cost
effective platform because it is
flexible and powerful
you're able to multiplex for several
hundreds to thousands of markers
in one single reaction you're able to
perform high throughput
1536 samples per chip or 3 000 samples
in a day on one single instrument and if
you want to increase the throughput you
can always
apply a modular approach adding more
instruments
so here's some data that will help you
validate our claim so we have developed
a small panel for bovine this is the
marker segmented by isac a 200 snip
panel
and we've also developed on the
recommendations of several kills
a 1500 snip panel for poor sign for
swine
and in both case and here that is what
we are showing that irrespective of the
size of panels
the performance is really good i mean
the panels will
have an average call rate of 98.5 and
6.3 percent they are really good
performing panels
and then we've also checked for intra
run and internal concordance by running
the same samples on the same chips
and also between chips and in both cases
for both panels
the concordance is really high and weigh
about the 99.9 percent in both cases
not only that we've actually done
orthogonal uh
comparison by uh taking the help of one
of our customers who had
access to the illumina blue chip so we
tested the same bovine samples on both
platforms and saw that
there's 99.4 concordance between both of
them
and so you can really trust this
technology works
and it works really well in comparison
to other
technologies on the market as well
so here's another example that uh
in collaboration with one of our
partners europe in biodiagnostics
we developed a sunflower 768 snip panel
where we used samples from the u.s grain
database
they had known samples and so we created
this
panel of snip markers which is available
and it was tested so we ran that in
in-house in the thermal lab
and european planet in their lab and
then we also tested it with the
historical
illumina area data that the u.s grain
folks had
and so you can see there was very high
concordance
between all these comparisons that we
have done
all in the range of 95 percent or 99
and above so this technology really
works
and it is offers you a pretty good
solution
uh here's another test that we had done
for the
usda where they wanted us to
screen the 19 beef producing bovine
breeds
and we did parentage analysis on them
using the bovine
200 marker snip panel and there again
the average call rate was 98.5 percent
so the panel
is a very well performing panel and in
fact
last year isag approved all of these
markers
uh into an expanded panel of 200 markers
and so this is readily available on the
market for the livestock customers
so overall our team have been enabling
the agriculture research you can see our
timelines we have
increased the sample throughput thereby
driving the sequence cost down
from 384 all the way to 1536 barcodes
it actually lowers your sequencing cost
by a multiple fold
we have also developed various tools
starting with the torrent suite software
which is the core technology core tool
that helps
with all the analysis and now last year
we've launched the agri-sum toolkit
which aggregates all this data and
presents it in a very usable
and interpretable format and we are
launching an improvement
later this year similarly we have
designed several off-the-shelf panels
which are readily available for you to
order
and use which is the isag bovine panel
and then we've also developed a canine
and feline parentage panel which
includes all the ic recommended markers
and we also have an additional panel for
canine and filain defects
over the years the our designs have
really improved and has been able to add
more and more
design for more and more complex markers
starting with snips
we have added our pipelines and designs
for
multi-nucleotide polymorphisms in dells
and we are developing pipeline for
structural variants
overall we have always been supporting
custom panels
because as you know every genome for
every species
is different and it has its own
complexities and so are our customers
our customers have
variety of interest people are looking
for genetic loci
for improving their production values
and somebody is
really looking at improving the disease
resistance
and the meat quality and and milk
quality
are in plants they are looking at faster
yields higher yields
disease resistance so every customer
comes with their own set of
interests and requirements and we are
able to incorporate
all of that in our custom panels uh so
here's a comment uh from one of our
early uh
kols who have adapted uh these where the
department of fisheries dr terry beacon
uh he has adopted our platform very
early on in 2017
and as a talk he shared that
we they we had helped them in developing
a panel for screening
euclid salmons so
our design team was able to design an
assay
which included 500 plus amplicons and
they could run
756 samples at a time on a single chip
giving them 95 million reads and he
praised our team really well and he says
that this was a great design
because he has seen uh several offers
american colleagues really struggle
to get such a panel going on uh an
illumina or a competitor platform
so uh our pioneers are really happy
uh using our platform so we and thermo
future scientific believe in
continuous improvement we really work
with our customers
in the past three years we have
developed over 150 custom panel designs
covering over 40 different species
we you can see all the plants and the
animals and aqua
uh species that are listed out there and
we are still counting
uh every year we get several projects
where people come to us
bringing in their requirements so we
continuously believe in improving our
designs
we work with our customers in meeting
their requirements and make all the
improvements needed
we work as partners we really believe in
in working together
and we are looking forward to work more
and
looking forward to develop such
partnerships and collaborations
in the southeast asia region
so you can check our customer
testimonials going to our website at
thermofisher.com at the genomics
there are several videos that will give
you provide more insights
and we have been empowering uh worldwide
agriculture
with various partners throughout this
past four years that we have launched
the agric
targeted gps which is a very
powerful flexible and cost effective
platform
i thank all our team members and now i
am open to
taking your questions and would be happy
to answer
and looking forward to developing some
partnerships in the near future
thank you
thank you thank you very much for the
wonderful talks front of us
um we have a couple questions coming
through here and
one of the first ones is how is aggro
seek unique from other
genotyping by sequencing solutions
so agric is an amplicon based targeted
system
so whereby you are developing panels uh
for the targets of your interest thereby
you will see a very high consistency and
accuracy
uh that's not the case when you say try
a
rad seek method which is more random and
a restriction enzyme based
platform so that's the uniqueness of
agric
because you're using a targeted amplicon
based system
your consistency and accuracy of
performance is really high
thank you and another question we have
here what is the key difference between
ample seek and accuracy
great question uh as i mentioned in the
presentation
our focus was uh like how
dr takashima and others have used the
iron amplifi chemistry as a basis a tool
however when it comes to production
customers
both in livestock and plant breeding
they really need
high throughput performance and for that
the iron amplifique chemistry is more
targeted where you are doing a research
based approach with lower number of
samples
uh here in agri-seq we were able to
scale it up
by modifying the workflow protocols uh
so that you are able to
run more number of samples and you are
able to generate
more data so there is a difference in
some of the
formulation which allows you to scale up
the number of samples and generate more
data
as needed by production customers both
in livestock
aquaculture and plant breeding companies
great thank you another question we have
here is how many markers can be included
on an aggressive panel
so technically the amplified chemistry
you could include
up to 23 000 markers but that's not
economically viable
so as we presented that agric is
a very good mid density platform
you can target anywhere between 50 to
5000 markers
of your interest and that's what we are
seeing that the market
after having done all the research with
microarray platforms
and after doing whole genome sequencing
they would like to pick and choose
relevant markers for the breeding
and the mid density is the right range
for using the agri-seq platform
great thank you another question we have
here is
can we generate multiple marker types in
multiple species
yes so uh the design the amplify
chemistry provides you the flexibility
to be able to design
primers for multiple uh markers in the
same
panel you could target snips you could
target
insertions and deletions or
multinucleated polymorphisms
or structural variants you can design
primers for all of them
and and still maintain compatibility
that these primers are specific and
sensitive to the targets that you're
trying to do
because it's one single reaction where
you're performing
a ultra multiplex amplification reaction
right
and then when you're trying to do
multiple species
you should make sure that you are
amplifying or making your libraries
individually for
each different species once all the
target libraries are amplified they're
all barcoded
cleaned up and normalized that is when
you can pool all of them
and run all the species together like
say if you are a service
a lab you may have bovine samples equine
samples
or you may have some corn and soy
samples so you prepare
individual libraries with their
respective panel
then combine all of them uh into one
and load it onto your chip and then you
can sequence them together thereby you
are optimizing your
uh your sequencing capability and uh
and optimizing on your uh effective
costs
great thank you for that a couple more
questions we have coming through
can we use markers or snip information
from microarrays for targeted genotyping
by sequencing panels as well
yes our design pipelines are created
such a way that
it helps in in customers bringing data
from other formats
most likely with microarrays because uh
people would have done the genome wide
association studies
and have done the genomic selection
studies where they have identified the
markers
so you have readily available
information for your marker
so that can easily be used for designing
the primer panels uh
for the targeted gbs aggressive platform
however what we recommend to our
customers is
in addition to those 30 or 40 or 50
bases that were used
uh in the micro array we would recommend
that they
increase it to at least 100 basis uh
provider sequences covering on both ends
of the
marker uh with about 100 bases and so it
allows you to create
better panels better sensitive panels
so that's that's our recommendation
ryan any more question
sorry we have another question here do
we need to buy additional software for
running the aggressive gbs
on the ion gene studio sequences
uh no so uh as again in the presentation
i showed uh
the iron torrent platform runs
or is integrated with the torrent suite
software
a suite it is an open source tool uh
that actually
comes along with our platform and all
the plugins are developed on open source
so all of this
is available uh and it comes with the
system
and we've also added the agri-sum
toolkit which is again developed with
open source uh
tools available out there and all of
this is integrated and comes along with
it
you don't have to pay any additional
charges for using the software
great thank you
[Music]
and that probably leaves us
at the end of our time here i just
wanted to
uh thank all of our speakers for today
and each one of us
uh as well as all of our audience
members for your questions as well
this ends the accuracy or agrigenomic
session for day two
we will now be taking a 15 minute break
before we start the sessions
in other tracks so you can have a coffee
break
and visit our booths learn a bit more
about some of the very exciting
promotions that we have made available
and you can also ask
therma pressure representatives there
any questions you may have as well
please also participate in the scavenger
hunting game
look for our icons in the environment to
win a number of prizes there
there'll also be a pop-up survey
appearing in a minute so please
complete the survey and it will help us
plan for these events in future
thank you again to our speakers and i
look forward to speaking to you all
again in about 15 minutes
thank you